a migrantes ahora gobernador de norte
renania westfalia el mayor estado de
alemania en términos de población y
también en términos de la economía él ha
ganado ese estado en 2017 en una campaña
un poco sorprendente porque
históricamente ese estado ha sido el
territorio de los socialdemócratas así
que él puede decir que él ganó una
campaña difícil a nivel estadual
mientras que al menos ahora no pueden
perdonar más ahora no puede decir eso
el nuevo resultado para su partido en el
estado de baviera así que la fed ha sido
históricamente un centrista inspirado en
el catolicismo político de su estado y
en realidad su virtud principal ha sido
de no ofender y puedes manejar campañas
de manera competente pero no
espectacular y en ese sentido es
básicamente lo contrario de marcos
sólida de quien es conocido como un
político más bien egocéntrico a veces
ruidoso
a veces populista básicamente son dos
personajes contrarios
ahora el partido ecologista en los
verdes ya había nominado precisamente
ayer a anna-lena verbos como su
aspirante a la cancillería de alemania y
ha trascendido que según algunos sondeos
estaría bien posicionada es esto así de
ser así qué posibilidades tienen ambos
candidatos entonces
en básicamente hay mucha incertidumbre
en esta elección primero porque a los
dos candidatos principales baby y la fed
no quieren tanta experiencia a nivel
federal incluso me aboqué nunca ha
contestado una elección realmente
un cargo ejecutivo y sólo tiene 40 años
así que ella sería la cancillera más
joven de la historia alemana en realidad
así que hay mucha incertidumbre cómo va
a ser la situación por ejemplo con la
pandemia en septiembre en octubre aunque
cómo van a ser los resultados de la
campaña de vacunación cómo van a
interpretar la gente la responsabilidad
del gobierno actual para esos resultados
así que es demasiado temprano para decir
qué va a pasar se han seleccionado dos
personas
interesantes y muy diferentes una mujer
de 40 años con poca experiencia a nivel
federal pero muy intelectual muy
cosmopolita
y un señor de 60 años con mucha
experiencia yo creo que es muchísimas
gracias por su presencia en france 24 en
español ha sido un placer dialogar con
ustedes